all right
[Music]
grab the charger open up the uh the deck
lid back here
plug right in
[Music]
a classic you know 1962 Beetle that's
that's fast it's clean it's quiet it's
reliable there's a lot less moving parts
and a lot less it can go wrong
thank you
[Music]
so our typical customer is one that
really loves their car either it has a
you know significance to the family
maybe it's been handed down or you know
a customer has driven it since high
school so typically
Automotive enthusiasts best describes
our customers
[Music]
foreign
electric drivetrain with Tesla batteries
in a car like this is is beautiful it's
a it's a joy to drive every day
foreign